[Musik]
das ist günstig
er spricht fließend uhr ja die sprache
der einheimischen hier an der ostküste
indiens ihre künstler in ihren aufgaben
machen
die aufgaben in der schweiz war
christian remo wenn seine krankheit des
zuließ in der mode und event branche
tätig und noch früher zur welt gekommen
ist christian 1968 in der romandie im
unteren rhonetal heute verbringt er die
hälfte seiner zeit in indien
er hat eine neue lebensaufgabe gefunden
schafft arbeitsplätze für benachteiligte
frauen alleinerziehende mütter indien
ist seine inspiration ein gegenentwurf
zu seinem leben als kranker mensch in
der schweiz wiederfinde
davon erzählt dieser film von einem dem
chaos indiens sein persönliches
heilmittel fand und von einem der dem
tod mehrfach von der schippe sparen
unsere wege kreuzen sich 19 97 zum
ersten mal ich zierte das cover und
[Gelächter]
christian wurde im heft porträtiert sein
leben mit hiv
mit 19 hatte er sich angesteckt ende der
80er jahre aids damals ein todesurteil
zehn jahre später verliert die krankheit
ihren mythos es gibt neue wirkungsvolle
medikamente
[Musik]
ali k
[Gelächter]
seit 25 jahren ist christian mit rolf
lied zusammen
wie wollen sie ein kleines mietshaus mit
großem garten am rande von zürich rolf
ist inhaber einer eventagentur er
finanziert das gemeinsame leben kümmert
sich um organisatorisches dass christian
hiv-positiv ist wusste rolf von anfang
an
[Musik]
christians krankheit war zu beginn für
beide eine große herausforderung
sie mussten einen umgang finden mit hiv
mit der angst vor aids mir das am ersten
und das ist sogar des sohnes großes
thema xiii vor allem schwule szene durch
die tamedia gehört das ist ein moment
sieht es ganz ganz breit besprochen
worden ist
ich habe das sehr schön wurde dass er
mir das ganze sofort und einfach so
offen und direkt und doom ist dass
danach wissen ihres problems sie also
von den richtern hat immer gesagt zum
durch immer irgendwo positiv blieben auf
1 grad richtig lebens ist ist er vor
allem beck sie wo ist die beiden so da
sagt macht hat darf das miteinander und
dann irgendein casting show wieder
besser und denkt dass dies bei den
extrem cool von amir zum das
trainerinnen akzeptieren und wieso ich
bin im moment in einer situation mit mit
dem partner wohl ganz leicht zweig ist
wo man teilweise gelöst hat die abtei
und gesetzen erwitter aber trotzdem ist
immer knapp optimismus sie zum
eigentlichen erfinder das runden zurück
ja und das ist beides sehr seitdem
wurden immer an bürger und wirklich
haben jetzt denkst aber war und bin
dafür
der kunde wartet mit der spitze ist und
den eventuell nur ein medikament dass
ich ein überholen das jetzt noch mal pro
woche für mehrere abgeschlossen gehabt
und jetzt ist fertig einfach nicht so
und daher bist du dein roth von der
monarchie
sich gegenseitig unterstützen und doch
eigene wege gehen so erlebe ich die
beiden christian dierolf gelernter koch
entdeckte für sich vor einiger zeit die
kraft der ju dischen küche sie hilft
gegen die nebenwirkungen der vielen
medikamente die cannabis wirkt das
problem und das parlament müssen nummer
mit dem medikament abgewehrt werden und
dass anni probiert mit ayurveda zu
minimalisiert
heute ist christians gesundheitszustand
stabil
doch es gab zeiten da wo gar noch 40
kilo und alle in seinem umfeld dachten
jetzt stirbt er
jetzt ist es vorbei das sich ganz vielen
zeitige frühjahr brief lust zum heim
rallye dakar um 7 reichenden gestoßen
was passt macht tempo bei diesen warum
machen wir jetzt und nicht normal
sondern einfach gottlos lecker genau das
taten die beiden vor zehn jahren
sie gründeten ihre stiftung realty trust
mit dem ziel arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
für bedürftige menschen in indien
produkte zu kreieren mit der lokalen
bevölkerung für den hiesigen markt ein
projekt als überlebenshilfe nach ihm
gegangen oder wohnungen verloren haben
da helfe trauer was sie überhaupt noch
in der situation nach der krankheit
machen also nach während so was mir
langsam auf ebays gegangen ist aber doch
nicht so gut
so ist es lieber dass wahnsinnig perfekt
durchorganisierte sehr uncool zu
langweilig bis dann hab ich dich runter
gewisse routinen ihnen der bund mit
bewegungen fließend zwischen wänden
das chaos indiens als lebenselixier
kaum gelandet stürzt sich christian ins
getümmel der stadt
wir sind also die sonderlinie ganz
[Musik]
jeder jede person jeder richterspruch
mit aus dem ver.di blieben werde
deswegen bin ich hier in der altstadt
von delhi im markt von jonny kopp trifft
christian seine händler stoffbänder und
glasperlen kaufte ein material das dann
zwei flugstunden weiter südlich von
frauen im dorf weiterverarbeitet wird
ja was ganz jährige studentin hat jetzt
ist qualitätsniveau wirklich stimmt und
die roten nur handgemachte produkte ihre
eher klein so schnell aber es geht hier
zu tag unglaublich gute kopie und sie
verkauft sie das sehr schnell für gold
was er eigentlich wahlkreis ich aber das
ist doch wirklich absolut hand machte
dort perfekt wunderschön die dorfstraße
von schramma john tripp uhr im
bundesstaat orissa heute wo die show
genannt
hierhin verschlug es christian vor zehn
jahren eine ayurveda-kur hatte ihn ins
leben zurück gebracht mit dem arzt eine
minder aus dem dorf wollte er in diesem
haus eine klinik aufbauen für die lokale
bevölkerung finanziert von der frisch
gegründeten stiftung
doch dieses projekt scheiterte der arzt
zu christian über den tisch geld
verschwand zurück blieb ein
scherbenhaufen und eine einsicht sehr
bewusst mit dem danach und trotzdem in
die dritte und vielleicht zum glück das
mir ja zum glück weiss hätte ich nie
erklären was wir gelernt haben also
durch eine extremsituation rosen ich
glaube die beste schulform im labor
finanziert also es kostet aber
schlussendlich ist es relativ günstig
wir müssen jene sounds so viel lernen
christian besann sich auf seine stärken
seinen sinn für ästhetik für design die
krankenstation wurde kurzerhand zur
werkstatt umfunktioniert zu einem
treffpunkt für frauen aus allen sozialen
schichten zu einem ort für fair bezahlte
arbeit
das ist die erste gemischte gruppe
überhaupt glaube ich auch nicht sagen wo
frauen ist der anschluss zu ganz tiefere
kraus der zusammenhalt der mannschaft
das gleiche gleis und und das ist
absolut super hornet auf dem markt doch
jede frau hat ihr eigenes schicksal zu
meistern
christian kennt jede familiengeschichte
jede lebenssituation von menschen
übernachten dorf das ist ein von der
ernst
dorfitter ganze gaga und sie hat
sie hatten eine so schwere behinderte
und erzielten mario adorf erzählerisch
er erzählt gesichter gott vor dort zu
dorffesten und erzählt ich sicher froh
ist von den göttern und so westphal mit
super also sehr schwere alkoholiker also
ja seit der 88 heftig gewackelt und sie
wohnt jeder tag immer und immer immer
immer noch und sich und so gern
also an der basis ist es immer
kokosfasern man braucht es ein
abfallprodukt osterberger angewiesen
krokus crocus gegend und mir ein ganz
ruhiger vor dem voll und das ist die
basis für fast alle produkte machen
perfekt sie hat unbedingt weil er dass
ich das akzeptieren aber wenn mir immer
zeigen und sie ist nicht sexy bringen
und die sie jetzt ein zu von unserer
allerbesten mitarbeiterin wurde sie
macht das großartig und dieses mega
stolz qualität ist ihm dem schweizer
wichtig christian kann nur einwandfreie
produkte in der schweiz verkaufen
im landesmuseum am weihnachtsmarkt in
ausgewählten shops
wenn christian in der schweiz ist sind
diese beiden männer zuständig für die
bestellungen und die qualitätskontrolle
sie heißen pinto und depot zwei junge
männer aus dem dorf die arbeit für die
stiftung hat ihren horizont geöffnet von
christian werden sie gefördert denn
erfahrung weitergeben war ihm schon
immer ein anliegen und ihre immer welle
teile immer gern teilt und und
investitionen ermöglichen was teile und
dann ist sofort sofort erkrankten mit
dem film mache teilen hat im ländlichen
indien noch immer tradition sein
frühstück bekommt christian kann
selbstverständlich von der familie vom
typus seinem angestellten dass er ein
teil der großfamilie geworden ist in
diesen zehn jahren im dorf merke ich
schnell bei unserem besuch
die blinde urgroßmutter liegt im sterben
100 vierjährig soll sie sein und
lebensmüde auf ein schwätzchen in ihrer
muttersprache lässt es sich trotzdem
gerne ein
[Musik]
eine partnerschaft mit dem a1 ist bisher
lange checkt obwohl so clarke sich aber
es existiert da wie die dörfer sowieso
nicht es gibt natürlich überall aber was
wir nicht klappt und jetzt müsste also
alle mini haupt mitarbeiter wie dieser
wüste zu mir herüber
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
damals
[Musik]
in gottlieben dahin schaffe dass man es
vielleicht besser findet machen letzte
finish machen leute das weniger
schliefer das mache ich weniger bekannte
gesehen die sich so oft so wenn ich um
auf dem feld szene wie das auch
mitdiskutieren sachen zusammen und
probieren alles zu optimieren
die werkstätten in denen christian
einkauft wo er mit seiner stiftung tätig
ist verteilen sich über den ganzen
bundesstaat orissa wo er hinkommt kennt
er die menschen und sie ihn er ist einer
von ihnen hier
er spricht ihre sprache ist mit den
händen schläft auf einer dünnen matte in
einem einfachen haus verzichtet auf
jeglichen luxus relativ einfach immer
wieder mal so ein nachbar jahren nach
drei jahren die füße bekommt also ans
nahe bei gestorben es wirklich ganz ganz
heftig und dann ja auch aber im generell
nein das ist jetzt wie zeige fünf jahren
nicht möglich weiß und was mich muss
machen aber ich glaube auch sowie blüht
da genauso wie sie aussieht ist mit dem
wasser was sie noch wochen bevor das
sich ziehen
ich kenne christian nun seit 20 jahren
radikal war immer in allem was er tut
sei es skilanglaufen wie in seiner
jugend sei es kraft training oder yoga
was er macht macht er richtig
[Musik]
also ich glaube ich bin mir da noch mit
der idee liefern sondern einfach etwas
machen und aber natürlich im ersten ist
es michael fuchs ich bin damals in der
situation sind die schlösser und
steuerung sind wir einfach nicht wissen
wo auf und dann ist plötzlich die
möglichkeit erkannt oder nicht ist für
andere aber vor allem mich wiederfinde
[Musik]
und so schließt sich der kreis
was die stiftung erwirtschaftet fließt
zurück in soziale projekte in den aufbau
von infrastruktur in dieser schule hier
mit 250 kindern übernimmt die stiftung
die kosten der waisenkinder und sie hat
drei zusätzliche lehrer angestellt
christi um nicht mitgezählt
[Musik]
dass es ohne kritische töne gibt und
dass diese bedürfen ist da probiere nur
dass die auch nie weg damit vor dem
hörer neben der stunden pro tag
dass christian hier wie eine art guru
behandelt wird macht absolut sinn ist
wieder um die situation in den schulen
zu verbessern und so auf aber erste
große christian ist der engagierte
gönner
er mischt sich ein gibt ratschläge und
stößt damit inzwischen auf offene ohren
ich rechne dass ich mir gerade sofort zu
akzeptieren es ist blauäugig sie das
damals glaube und der angedachte nicht
einfach gerade ein kraftakt und der
schweiz und in einer von der jetzt nach
einer lösung
bitte deinen kredite machen dranbleiben
hat sich gelohnt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in indien kann christian römer seine
visionen umsetzen
und er hat seine aufgabe gefunden die
ihn am leben hält der erkenntnis ist
enorm lasershow immer wieder und das ist
sehr schön
ich wäre aber schon vor 20 jahren zum
sterben weil sie den richtigen moment
und runter denn und jeden moment berater
von dem her ist das hinhaut nicht und
das gemüse das lager jetzt wahnsinnig
dass mehr europa ja wohnen wurden
gefunden hat mein gott was passiert
jetzt ist wird dort sache nicht nur
älter und das hätten wir vor bayern
bewegt jetzt ist es einfach so wie sie
ist und ich geniesse ist einfach
[Musik]
[Applaus]